how are you Curtis I'm good rich I was
sorry I could get a hold a minute ago I
was I was taking a little pit stop on
interstate 95 by apology no problem I
don't think I want to get any deeper
into the details but I appreciate let's
let's uh let's talk more about the
birdies and pars and whatnot
what did you make of Patrick Reed's
victory yesterday Curtis so much being
discussed as to who he is and what
excitement he'd engenders or not what's
your take on it Curtis well you know as
somebody who's done it I like to see and
now talks about it I like to see
somebody break out and okay he's not the
most known person now he is he's had a
steady career climb from college golf
all the way up he is overcome he's a
survivor I'd like to say he's uh he's a
Louisville lovable villain a little bit
yesterday because he beat Rory and
Jordan speith and Ricky and all the ones
that we thought would have a chance and
they did have a chance but it doesn't
stop a good young player like Patrick
from from beating them a oh they're not
they're not unbeatable
I admire his courage yesterday although
he did have a three shot lead so he had
some mistakes he could make a still win
and he didn't make a couple mistakes but
you know the biggest surprise for me of
the day was Rory in the way he played
hmm why self well I thought he would put
a lot of heat on Patrick I thought even
though Patrick had a three shot lead and
I thought he would probably win if he
just run the numbers only I thought was
extremely motivated
that doesn't make putts for you but he
seemed to be playing really really well
he's putting well and from the first tee
shot going straight right shocked me and
he just didn't have it so and then but
Spieth did it would tell me if I should
believe or not him saying he never
looked at the leaderboard once until he
hold
out in 18 Curtis is a possum no I can't
I think it's almost impossible they're
they're on every green now they're not
they're not the high-tech flashy that we
have on tour but they're on every green
which I kind of like the old-school too
they're on every green how do you not
look at this the leaderboard and if you
can't get more just one I do I love
looking at the leaderboard to see how
only not I how I stood how everybody
else stood and I think you really as
towards case being so far back it really
didn't make much difference but it does
dictate how you play you know your
strategy on how you play on how you
stand so but anyway when around he had
my gosh it was it was it looked like
could it be could it be and then he ran
out the hole yeah and then 18 that was a
I was a bizarre undoing on 18 Curtis I
as I said at the top of the show I've
never seen in all my years of watching
major golf certainly at the Masters
somebody on 18 with a second shot three
hundred yards away that sounds like
something that would happen to me well
you know when they put the tee back 40
or 50 yards 10 years ago or so it really
is a very narrow shoot but let's don't
let's don't think that that the Mike
Schmidt reached his glove out there not
for Touring's fall out of there George's
ball went up and kissed that lip so
Jordan kept acting like where did that
come from well it was always there so
anyway he dropped straight down he's
lucky drop straight down and then manage
to you know not make par but you know
whatever the case it was a helluva round
a hell of a tries and his ability to
play gust international riches it's
phenomenal stuff it's right there with
Jack and Tiger how he plays and he
doesn't have the longest game though
he's plenty long to be dominant the
world he's not the longest out there he
just he knows the golf course he
believes in the golf course and he
certainly can make all pots
what was that golf course for you Curtis
what was it like
no no what was that golf course for you
and your career the one that you just
said you know what this sets up for me I
know every inch of this place I'm going
to dominate uh you know what
was a couple that I like she was good I
liked Augusta even though it was a
little bit long for my game I like to
Gus and I like to think I played it
reasonably well but it makes you think
Augusta when you left there Sunday night
and then the next Monday morning which
is now I was exhausted I was exhausted
because of the of the thinking you had
to go on not only off the TV but second
shots you had to think exactly where
he's going to miss it
were you going to hit it Hayes how can I
get this below the hole because the
speed of the greens and then trying to
putt the greens
I was never comfortable until the
weekend because in the day they were
faster than anything we'd ever seen and
then with the slopes there were it was
frightening at times it was you played
such defense for four days so a couple
more questions for Curtis Strange after
another 2018 masters how sustainable is
Patrick Reed success do you think Curtis
you know I think it's that all depends
on him I mean when you reach the
pinnacle or close to the pinnacle some
people human nature lays back a little
bit we've seen it time and time again
but I think he's a little bit of a
bulldog I think he's a throwback he's a
tough guy
and I think he's going to progress I
know his teacher really well and he's
going to stay on it I think the way he's
wound to be successful to continue to
push himself I think he'll come that
he's not it's not going to be a fast
track to number one in the world but I
think he will continue to try to improve
and win his one tournament or two terms
a year and who knows he's been in this
major hunt before he might win another
one or two we'll just have to wait and
say but let's give him some time in last
one how should we look at Tigers
performance this weekend Curtis you know
I could tell you I think we all look at
the same way I think we expected a
little bit too much and I like to think
rich I was the voice of reason but I
think we were asking too much early in
the week could he win yes he could have
won but was it realistic probably not I
thought if he finished to play solid to
his top ten it would have been a good
week he didn't seem to play well striker
well draw the ball particularly well the
first three days yesterday left a good
taste in his mouth but I think when he
leaves last night I think he had a
decent taste in his mouth because he
shot 69 yesterday you really seem to
play well and we got to remember that
this is all part of the comeback six
months ago we didn't know if he'd hit
another golf shop ever so he's doing
well this is all one week of the
comeback and let's watch him progress if
he does for the next six months yeah but
hearing him say he wanted to go back
into the gym certainly concern me based
on the history of over working out etc
etc we you know we just don't know if in
fact he does work out or any of these
athletes do too much beyond what they're
what helps them in their sport but that
seems to be the norm now I appreciate
you calling in you got it you guys thank
you red you got a skirt Easter on the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience